him from hi Erica my name is platen I'm
a portrait photographer and I was rather
interested in your question about
changing my life and how I could make a
difference so as I say I'm a
photographer if I have any Talent it's
now time to put it to good use and try
to stop celebrating the celebrated in
the powerful which is what I've been
doing for 20 years and start capturing
and promoting and celebrating the people
who have been robbed in power the people
who have had their human rights and
civil liberties and stripped away and if
people have shown great courage in the
face of oppression you have so they will
be my new subjects for the future I mean
I will be their champion and I will
fight harder for them everybody else has
in my record so that's it that's my
message to you and to my new subjects
thank you very much